I have a [ __ ] bad gas but [ __ ]
backward drops a lot has happened what
the [ __ ] did it happen oh the dog told
us to go to Ted can be faster Merle
guess we can't fast you a [ __ ] sucks
jesus [ __ ] walk like 10 miles oh but
we got flora I think we can put inside
at light place with the girls crying
where the girls are our powers dead oh
[ __ ] if I'd like come for backup oh [ __ ]
what does that say oh it's closed before
I was just check it out sandwiches take
that was Sony were [ __ ] hungry this 56
rock and roll equals devil music the
plot can I gotta free now what the [ __ ]
okay did I get the sandwich oh um this
is hot no oh wait no how are you ladies
in there I think right holy [ __ ] what's
their dead [ __ ] why do I like so unhappy
okay I'm good with girls like it though
will the wheel [ __ ] like yeah here
weekend very depressed very the press
but don't worry beautiful I got your
precious flower here
do you think we're left I get ya ya ya
hear she liked the [ __ ] looks like
playing at night I still can't get it
anyway I guess would go back to the
house [ __ ] is that God like me know
something's here that I think I'm [ __ ] I
have anything that can hey sandwich
watch [ __ ] out of here Oh what the [ __ ]
is this with these books over here ah
lastly
okay I guess back to my own place deep
in the woods oh [ __ ] sir disguising
always try to tear her stuff what r
equals what the [ __ ] is that I get him
to bed what happened that burn take your
tire I don't that middle thing was it
sucks for you sir this guy don't need
that for sure yeah the [ __ ] hug oh
yeah yeah it's switch look creepy it's
okay you think you like more food looks
over here oh how do we cope robot no
[ __ ] way I have the pants already
like a [ __ ] one two three four five um
okay and King
[ __ ] oh it's a statue okay wait what was
the other ones yeah yeah take that now
it's okay that's [ __ ] creepy okay
wait oh wait no dogs in there yes yes ok
guess so weird look it's ok we're
[ __ ] food No ah that were to Tico's
that kk i'll just shower wait it's a bit
of [ __ ] cake oh yeah right now no
it's one there yeah I don't know raise
be both fun thus so sad I'll [ __ ]
perish
this one there's Kate let's think in
that room oh it's a bath of this method
we're just there a second ago the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] took our [ __ ] cake oh
yeah so it's [ __ ] stole it look how
does a cake chill on the ground you
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey [ __ ] oh my
another [ __ ] [ __ ] ok yes we got a
[ __ ] fun remember that bird Oh small
help us save us one more one more for
good luck thank you can wait what's this
way I see an apple if I can't say yeah
[ __ ] i guess we're now let's do it
what's this way hey [ __ ] fish is hard
Rogan don't when they can give it up
that hit up hill
um ok hey Jesus God is not equal chicken
Oh looking for you i'm [ __ ] chicken
outfit give over you no way how he's
trying to get the stuff Hawk can't talk
damn i can't hug them yeah baby you're
weird I can't I [ __ ] get down I got
to get off boy have a [ __ ] hang it
down a [ __ ] dr. get help did [ __ ]
stuck here
[ __ ] alrighty now okay tiger fish oh I
can take it off it's guys [ __ ]
horrifying oh maybe I'm like fast travel
for that and this guy's looks so freely
I guess our thank you say I'm a good guy
[ __ ] it's almost daytime sky for you
know okay well oh [ __ ] that quickly
go bury that thing and flower rom before
gets like daytime shut right much time
wait occ a night I have anything for
this thing yeah [ __ ]
who's this [ __ ] Perry they were no not
you plant the thing that was dark cub
fun hello man hello hmm what does she
want oh how she likes music though you
give her cool tunes oh yeah what's that
oh you seeing Cuba [ __ ] actually wow
this girl is happy as I Kyle hello oh
thanks thank you is a guy who else has
huh and I forget this and I thought you
can't you stop and do something go play
with her huh Oh me which African hug her
now Oh act like hug everyone in this
town I big goal of dropsy I'm gonna give
that lady a sandwich like being same
shop say I'm not job Sam this guy okay
hitting in here what's in here oh we're
heroes was at night with actual people
we could say we got [ __ ] lady there
she is she add weight well she's behind
here and use checks everything changing
sandwich not happy you should give her
sandwich oh and then I guess I just
wasted two of those let me go feat that
one lady is like [ __ ] starving
rihanna is that we're talked oh it's a
guy the right hello lady I'm here to
bring you a sandwich hmmm thank ya thank
ya I kiss ur lips
oh yeah he Josh got crime should have
this [ __ ] no I just kiss her some more
tell me hey [ __ ] dog get on there
the [ __ ] i know the shares oh [ __ ] hello
oh this is great you now okay times it
out sunny you see big changes anything
different from yet and thank Tom let's
makes it so much easier anything here
maybe take early morning and this last
hour let's see some happens
all right you don't know what the [ __ ]
that is I have anything but there is
basically like [ __ ] you look great okay
I'm really a delay its do this [ __ ] is
doing over here hmm that's care what
does it look please that's cycle money
really not let me go to the nightclub at
night roof dusk
yep yep done in to see more crazy murder
things about me yeah yeah cuthbert not
bourbonnais what is this oh I just want
some [ __ ] show people your fun ok see
you see anything in particular anything
of a tickler they're looking at me like
what you see oh yeah yeah I can't get ok
now it's a truly dark right now I think
so i'm checking out that ain't really
have in here I got they have to give
hope you like to see me dance mr. sure
ok or maybe it was gas tire I think I
started fat so I can fast travel
hospital I don't were seen us what a lot
of [ __ ] man was that
okay he says have I been here I haven't
been here yet okay play cool drop see
you know I get kicked out nearest a
[ __ ] clothes I better not oh hell 0 a
conscription she says is [ __ ] [ __ ]
I guess he's a third class set of
sentence they get it exchanged you see
the white guy but I get it ok we get
back my [ __ ] camp oh dude get your
[ __ ] back here bro yo shad yet
that'll work uh-huh he loves me about
his fellow clown king
I was so jealous what does that feel too
good i think is gonna die the [ __ ]
have a man he's it goes way up
oh it's just the area wasn't allowed to
before yeah no way yeah I've actually
brought back for me what the [ __ ] no way
what is that says wasting it Lola
sighing Jesus nice [ __ ] nuts has he
likes whoa [ __ ] shower today yeah sorry
though is that she's very [ __ ] nuts
smells yes sir the [ __ ] down you attend
ok keep my gun you what the [ __ ] is that
hungry
this work [ __ ] okay I can't do that cuz
I calves it away walking it ok ok go
scare me what is that wait Doug you know
my heart's and explosions anything
unique over here what is that ok
there's a packet you to know a lot about
it what is that yeah okay why are you
barking stud get that [ __ ] k ok see
where this guy's sleeps piss on a [ __ ]
thug fake I'm sorry ok right here right
here and take a look this one more time
it's a load [ __ ] where it's at you just
feel right what's this what is that part
now oh yeah it's quite as a button
[ __ ] a
he's not hearing is king the key to this
guy huh keV headed I'll get us out of
here he can know those here he's a cup
synthase losing the money Dada faith and
give us it yeah you sure
I'm Eric with the key there oh the key
of fans will [ __ ] stupid is that you
know to [ __ ] grass ok take this
disgusting [ __ ] all right there I get it
okay with that but again wait should I
get up this away hey it's crazy [ __ ]
here we go yes that's disgusting yeah
yeah come on let's get past them okay
gonna hurt you tough [ __ ] um drop it and
kill this guy
you
oh thank you sir oh I can't matter the
same okay
is that what I need to load up he said I
can remove this one more no no what the
[ __ ] that is it oh my little mousey
friend he's following us now I can I
like that but oh well oh [ __ ] i can use
the mouse to go into holes the [ __ ]
way please come out I'm just kidding
that Rousey thick gravy film hey hey
Swiss okay I guess [ __ ] out of here oh
my god if y'all worked it out just like
I saw my song
oh my goodness he [ __ ] died oh no I
got to heal him we need to heal him get
him some meds that proud I got a [ __ ]
Mouse now that bed pad it'd be a lot for
us to get out of here huh jeez you gonna
hear the heartbeat of [ __ ] Mouse
what's this way though what is this I
check this out before no okay he's like
go [ __ ] yourself that last one will see
a grave what's over here on a shot over
there she's this [ __ ] to left oh
thanks rich you smell sweet front of him
oh that's like [ __ ] yeah
let's get out of here let's fly this
shot what is that I really have no idea
what to do here Oh sky see if there's
yeah sure here all right I should look
to see who the [ __ ] people to lock it
are it's a two scientists or something
tell em I was gonna get that cheese yeah
it was actually a pretty good game i
thought this is a terrible but it's
actually be good oh you give this girl
the suite next time oh hey like that oh
my gosh it was she blonde Wow she wants
a boy he enters la la so is this way
right now before that let me just get to
that you just check out what that a
whole is where is it home not here well
I'm just check real quick and say holes
here [ __ ] Mouse here and they
affected [ __ ] here where you got that
clip
and I like this not everything okay okay
beyond the church and the church that
ralphs Europe take a look for me and
then get else what the [ __ ] is that holy
[ __ ] that's a nice nice job there goes
our latest thing ever seen a cirque
himself through this dead yes sir Oh
with tomato I all she died out this guy
selling oh this is your guys oh here and
I don't even know how the [ __ ] do I give
anything here's interactable that is him
huh his wife is [ __ ] dead oh here you
can just like finds where that messy go
Coco anything just heartbroken is it
here's your back door chase now okay I
can't something on can I yeah well like
I goes that guy okay wait be honest
ok I got it a hospital we don't get this
truthfully that thing sciguy's is a
[ __ ] breath I doubt she talked about
this this is she sandwiches can I give
this [ __ ] a singer what the [ __ ] goes
on here [ __ ] I'll go where
rock girl then I tried this retic
welcome genocide Wow take a trapper saw
what is that can't put like a tomato
there Kenny now that i'm sure i was like
an animal trap for selecting well acts
right there you know okay wait what's
this toxic I'm something like a sewer
grates oh no the sugar it was at the
other medical center [ __ ] okay we are
really far often what we gotta go [ __ ]
today I cannae that sucks you can't test
show that's okay this guy doesn't
slavery just [ __ ] walks just like I'm
wearing our story just [ __ ] locks
oh great okay canker it just takes it
away oh no any money for you if I did I
want to give it to you that's for sure
no you're right yeah right now that kind
of LC go ahead no cheater best what is
this oh [ __ ] hello ever don't let soon
as we feet how much to [ __ ] your linear
00 can we do there wait no I did it the
[ __ ] Oh
I can't actually go any further oh what
the [ __ ] I guess I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here oh no drops is allowed
[ __ ] [ __ ] now she can go there oh [ __ ]
mouse he can't even go there oh hello
sir right over there check it out oh oh
[ __ ] pressed upon be open it Sookie
Anna and [ __ ] it up oh we're home we're
[ __ ] ourselves yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay oh man was hella uh-huh Jesus I
can't pass into port can I de chine know
a chad mmm I like her I get music right
uh-huh please have to give everyone the
right to music
Oh Gibby jaana hai had zero to this
place again now who can do what we can
do now you know can't go on it yeah
that's all this Christmas shakers astray
write it down place sure they do here
this [ __ ] again yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] I
like at a loss here I think I directed a
leer place not just I don't know his
languages is weird it looks familiar
it's AG weird you like me you know i got
it again like you I see you back
hmm i think the alien thing is this way
I check it check it oh wow Oh see the
shift inherited that I think like a
weird [ __ ] up Jesus what the [ __ ] is
that tomato sir how do you like that bag
that will do okay okay oh that's the
girl okay wait wait yeah yeah put right
there [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] chillin a
cartoon there
looking around I can't how's that cave
well I haven't been here no bats or
vampires us where the band bar wow she's
a vampire don't have it like a holy
trinity thing I can know what the [ __ ]
this place is that Oh vaporize can't go
to a day so I could just show it during
the day and kinky chick with boys out
can I go here and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this can't remember
anyway oh oh I'm asking over there oh
don't worry a Justin actually chicken I
am almost that I lost her words here
okay well I'm still exploring I'm stuck
swine I don't know ok let the mouse to
go from [ __ ] no mousy mousy Gaga [ __ ]
drops Roy and a hole though what is it
sir dad
what is this I go here I can't remember
[ __ ] anymore I don't even remember
honestly this was huge alien sightings
bio era will suppose the alien so what's
the cost money ok get some [ __ ] money
it's a [ __ ] money okay I got to go
back on the way off hmm check in this
way [ __ ] oh this count soup
hey guys it's like thank you I like it
[ __ ] hmm ok all right let me just go
back to [ __ ] guy he's like sec way I
miss something where's it got mouthful
of the [ __ ] house or why the shower
huh shops are just walking all over town
says I'll touch his [ __ ] ok mmm oh no no
I think this way to get out Hank there's
two things with the [ __ ] okay right here
right here no bag no bag status' that
[ __ ] is hey Mouse come they can ask a
yeah yeah yeah i shay here will [ __ ]
your disk
hey second time octave a yeah I'm a sea
gal investigate now say investigate
scare him scare him huh get there
I get okay nothing nothing chocolate
chopped see it's your turn shine it's
your time to shine well if I get a
[ __ ] coin what is that let's [ __ ]
die can't we r fruit can I know today
after nothing nothing now see what can
you do hear nothing ok ok oh I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here you get fast
shuttle can I [ __ ] sucks I can't
fasho speed up tent thing though wait
capital ooh captain up with a hit market
we know I get the twin off from here
I get [ __ ] here okay okay go back go
back I know what the [ __ ] this is get
the [ __ ] out of here you actually using
a lot okay now say get that shiz I sick
throat tornado at it Oh Rossi go in
there now
oh wait quite have a coin oh yes sir I
you actually [ __ ] young yes sir very
happy thank you hug him okay hey guys
what [ __ ] up games I to say this is
what a [ __ ] game wait can I go in this
alley now was he blocking this one and I
got mouse you can I go in here oh I can
go into your Prada right she's you sleep
here that's it go yeah yeah cat cow and
get the [ __ ] outta here 24 7 it says is
this [ __ ] 24 7 what is that totally
fine i tell anyone closed but really
work in a record store it was always
closed going
oh I have my a music oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do here he looks
you're a girl right you y haga I don't
know that metal thing is damn easy back
then did ya ok [ __ ] you guys wait sir my
solar mezzo else huh ok ok mal [ __ ]
here
yes getting [ __ ] desperate for sure
get [ __ ] dash bear over here
something unique here no what is that Oh
me makin it is a collar no I dog get in
there I'm a/c guy there
yep then oh it's the guy here we go here
we go now's the time to give it them
okay oh thank you sir thank you I'm Agra
I love you our Lord and let a hug him
hug your job see you earned it you've
earned it Oh God we was [ __ ] the
matter with mccoy elijah now say yeah
you get anything it come on okay
oh okay this guy's here forget that
vampire thing okay I guess I just
everyone's right now it's in here Oh
quick boy boy boy go enjoy gordito wine
I got myself some kind and I got so much
ado yeah yeah yeah okay let's see what
the [ __ ] is going on here Gary something
but oh [ __ ] that's like p.m. machine
forgiven really busy thing I contaminate
the food
oh thank you ma'am can't a scout out
there's my mouse there hello hello Thank
at okay
I'll give it pressing ok sick and that
Mouse go in there this is joint handling
friends yeah it's like the Spencer guys
like like that Oh may I leave this on
the altar [ __ ] Wow fair that I wasn't
out there who's [ __ ] window
Oh what the [ __ ] hi IRA slowly just
slowly and painfully getting through
here Jesus that look the [ __ ] going on
here yeah yeah you know jia li na jale
not what the [ __ ] other that day I can't
it's unlocked can I get out of your cup
yes sorry ok I can't drop see I pray in
the gate door it can go in now oh [ __ ]
my camera I'm [ __ ] camera scene
called cops yo go go go go go
hack hack the system oh wait but how can
i hanker for that son Oh hope I can do
it I can join you Oh [ __ ] eight what
is that cake no no no anything here [ __ ]
oh no the door shut the door Oh [ __ ]
a okay i'm saying i'm gonna has right
kiddo [ __ ] dead what the [ __ ] are
they doing here lies our night club
thing here 00
hey says oh what the [ __ ] I need that
pill weight okay agenda Oh can I get the
word with the kill that guy you [ __ ]
insane always make sure there's nothing
else I can get here first or try to get
that egg murdered I can't go back to
attack mode [ __ ] it's got to be purpose
of that right that or someone be with
your back kill him kill him oh wait no
[ __ ] yeah destroy us ohh fry this try
this oh [ __ ]
huh gonna make you the bumpers come here
oh it's gonna take em both the other
beers compass [ __ ] security thing
good wait can't take that thing now is
that guy dead though no chiz this guy is
really working now I guess they just
can't take it how about [ __ ] yeah I do
what's that
[ __ ] oh I must get another guy in here
if I can't do that no sorry okay oh I
can just go in there now Jesus it's AI
don't wisely on how the [ __ ] heading
into that right now see you back in
there now okay Jesus Christ okay so is
that ok huh guys yes yes
hey Jesse got that Madison gotta get
that Madison done your well I've done
you well this guy's like a [ __ ] thief
okay okay i guess not does it say yeah
what the [ __ ] okay Rick this guy up and
she gonna take that
[ __ ] huge pill now there I sell it or
do I give [ __ ] magic potion to the
sick guy can recall don't know if I can
give her another wasting more [ __ ] on
them bio era take turn into medicine
that well I'm sucking [ __ ] give you a
[ __ ] yeah
have anything to upgrade that thing I'm
sure here all right sir what the [ __ ]
this is how we won't die hitting it over
physic more planning [ __ ] that shitty
the FBI yeah by one another oh no
[ __ ] way is he dead oh no [ __ ] way
this is getting dark [ __ ] fast oh not
again yeah no [ __ ] way whatever oh no
did I like mess up no now well yeah of
course now get as far scripted she says
I've done [ __ ] up and then I guys not
like a green thing if I can kill that
guy yeah
oh okay yeah everything's okay those of
you too Leah don't visit us those I like
to speak with you sir you're welcome
chapter 2 chain yes okay Cat Cat Cat
that was huge dude um oh yeah so [ __ ]
up okay well we're gonna we're gonna
leave about that right now we're gonna
leave it at that okay because things are
getting [ __ ] up I thank you